how is wedding planning mama fine it's
you know I think it's always great to
celebrate love I think you know it's the
most important thing in the world you
learn unconditional love ideally from
your mother and if you find it in your
life you're blessed do you know what
you're wearing yet no something like
this I'm just trying to get through the
day and Chris you love him I think it's
great yes your big event everyone's been
giving you glowing honours about all the
hard work you do for today what does it
mean to celebrate best buddies
well I think celebrating remarkable
women remarkable mothers so many mothers
who have special need kids are really
working kind of tirelessly to raise
their children give them access to all
the same things that everybody else has
so to be here to celebrate remarkable
mothers is a great gift so I my kids are
coming and I'm happy to be here with my
brother it's 30 years 30 years of this
important work and you've given over
your career in your life so much to
giving back to the good works why is it
so important you to live your life this
way well I was raised that way so I
think it's important to try to raise
your kids that way and also I think it
makes your life meaningful it gives you
a sense of purpose in your life and
sense of meaning and I think that's what
helps you get up every day and go out
and face the world is if you have a
vision and a mission and it's not about
you
[Music]